not enough to walk in here is a Canton
class of 1995 member man has been in the
Hall of Fame for 22 years the first ever
Seattle Seahawk as well that group now
goes to for such enshrined members with
Kenny easily going in a teammate of
Steve large and good to see use a great
Greg see you rich
22 years yeah I can't believe it's gone
by like that isn't it incredible
yeah it is now there's four members of
the Pro Football Hall of Fame
Kenny easily going in Ombudsman
something particularly special it really
is I got to play at Kenny's entire
career which unfortunately wasn't long
enough but what a player he was
incredible I remember the first time I
ever saw Kenny Easley he was out of the
practice we were practicing on our own
before training camp started and I was
out there running routes and I think Jim
Zorn or Dave Krebs told me passes and
and items is Jim Zorn because we always
worked later and we are out there
playing he came out you know he's a
safety but he came out to cover me I'm
thinking we just drafted this guy in the
first round I think we you know what's
he doing he's a safety he's not a corner
and so I tried running like a few routes
on him and and I was successful running
routes on him but not that successful I
thought this guy is going to be good
because he's a safety covering a wide
receiver you know and he's not supposed
to be able to do that but he was a
really special player and I love the
fact that I got to play with him and not
against it well he's he's the guy that I
I think isn't getting the most tub out
of everybody that's coming in here with
Jason Taylor and LaDainian Tomlinson
being first-ballot guys and Terrell
Davis and and Kurt Warner being former
Super Bowl MVPs and even more Anderson
gets a little bit of pop because he's
he's got he's a kicker we just saw
actually Yan Stenner udas is chilling
out outside he now has company in the
Gaffney Department here at the drug cage
Kenny's not a first round Hall of Famer
only because his career lasted seven
years and there's a lot of people that
say well you should have guy play seven
years and getting the Hall of Fame I
don't know we have two other players
that are Hall of Famers that played
seven years but kid he was just a really
he's one of those special guys that I
think really deserved you know notice
and he got it this year finally but
there's no question on mind if Kenny
would have played ten
one of years he would have been a
first-ballot Hall of Fame now taking a
look at your career Steve you were a
fourth-round selection not by the
Seattle Seahawks but the Houston Oilers
took you out of knowledge out of Tulsa
oh why did how did how did you get to
Seattle well it's an interesting
question okay I bumped it was in the
second year coaching the Houston Oilers
and hey they had no first-round draft
choice and no third round draft choice
so in the second round they drafted Mike
barber the tight end who played for a
number of years for he slaughters good
tight in and in the fourth round they
drafted me so I was the second pick even
I was in the fourth round and so I
thought now I you know I for sure going
to make the Oilers because I'm their
second pick right and I go into camp and
they've got they've gotten just a lot of
good receivers a veteran perceivers from
other teams and I'm competing against
and I never really learned the system
never really understood what the coach
wanted me to do and so when you do that
and the quarterbacks at that time could
be real aggressive with you there was no
five-yard rule or anything like that and
it just it was intimidating to me so I
got a second chance they've actually
bumped hills called me into his locker
and said you know Steve we're gonna let
you go give you a chance with somebody
else thanks but no thanks
and so they waved me they actually
raised me and then recalled me and
traded me to the highest bidder
which was happened to be the Seattle
Seahawks and kind of my ace in the hole
was the fact that Jerry room had been my
offensive coordinator at the University
of Tulsa for the past three years and
had just become the receivers and
quarterbacks coach in Seattle and more
importantly he had implemented our
passing game in the Seahawks playbook so
when they like they said you know split
right 76 I knew exactly where to go and
what to do even though I hadn't been in
their training camp I'd run those place
for three years in college so it was a
real advantage for me and a boost in my
confidence and and Jerry was of course
very encouraging for me and to me and
that just gave me the shot Steve Largent
here on the Richardson show and now
obviously everybody knows about the
passionate
fanbase that the Seattle Seahawks have
and travel within the 12 etc etc what
was it like though to be there ground
zero day one of the Seattle Seahawks
franchise what started up I would tell
you the fans have always been that way
they have really acted more like a
college fanbase in a pro fanbase where
they just love the team Lin lose or draw
and we lost a lot in the early years but
in a kingdom in the kingdom and you know
talk about loud I I would rival the
noise of the Kingdome versus the stadium
they have now with anybody because they
were saying a lot it was really loud in
that Kingdom because the noise didn't
have anywhere to go so it was it was
very encouraging and they are very
enthusiastic and I'm really glad now
that they've had a chance to go a couple
of Super Bowls three Super Bowls and
when once and and you know it's a fan
base it deserves that what do you think
about what is going on with the Seahawks
they just keep on winning and they keep
on keeping their guys they just resigned
kam chancellor now and they they got the
core group and then they have these
young up and comers because Pete Carroll
just says it I don't care who you are
what your pedigree is if you can play
you can get out there but then there's
the hole Russell Wilson and and Richard
Sherman apparently that there's a little
bit of friction richard says it's just
you know brothers who argue but what do
you think of it Steve legend well number
one I think that Pete Carroll does a
fantastic job of coaching his team any
team he's a good coach he makes those
guys work and so when they get to a game
it's easy and I've really impressed with
his demeanor with the team and the way
they respond to it and so that they
couldn't get a better coach than Pete
Carroll but the team I think this is
going to be a real critical year for him
because of two reasons one they've got
an offensive line that's a huge question
mark and was a question mark last year
and proved to be a question mark
throughout the season and this year that
I don't know that they're any better
but we're gonna have to prove themselves
I think that would be a real issue for
the team the second issue is running
back they really have not gotten another
Marshawn Lynch
there's not another Marshawn Lynch but
they haven't got anybody comparable to
him in my opinion so there's got to be
somebody that jumps out of the pack and
plays running back for him because you
just can't put all that pressure on
Russell Wilson and receivers that he has
to have no running game and that's Pete
Carroll's bread you know meat potatoes
is is have a strong running game and a
great defense and that's how they won
the pass Steve Largent Pro Football Hall
of Famer fresh out of the nichkhun
luncheon here on the Richardson show art
let make me a fly on that wall what was
it like in that room today it really is
a fun time because it's the only time
that we come to the two Canton to the
Hall of Fame and we get together and
it's just the players in the hall if
there's nobody on the outside in there
and and so it's really fun to you know
just joke around with the guys and hear
about their life and talk about their
families and joke around with each other
and then welcome a new class of 2017 how
does that get done is there a program
yeah there's a program yeah yeah yeah
Willy Lanier is kind of the emcee this
year even says last year I don't know if
it will be or not well because that used
to be deacons role right it was
yeah Mitch's role before it yeah so
right so it's Willy Lanier now living
here yeah he's been he's been doing it
for the last out of five or six seven
eight years so but it's it's really it's
really informal and there's a lot of
jokes a lot of laughing and some sincere
times too when guys are talking about
their careers and what it means to them
to be in the Hall of Fame and welcoming
the guys in from this year's class and
and just sharing stories sharing your
life so you stand you raise your hand
and stand up I mean how's that work yeah
they'll have somebody with a microphone
in this case it was Curtis Martin and if
you raised your hand he'd come over and
give you the mic and let you share your
story and sometimes it's just to
congratulate the guys on a class that
came in this year sometimes it's to
relate a story that happened to them
when they were inducted and how they
felt
and how special it is but you can't come
out of that leading out of that time
with those hall-of-famers those they're
in there and have been there for 22
years like myself or those that are just
being inducted and and walk away and not
really understand how special this place
is to these guys and they did somebody
stand up and give them the way it's been
described to me in the past
give message of don't screw this up well
there used to be a message like that
there definitely was when I was inducted
what do you mean and there's well
there's a message about don't screw it
up
with your life somewhere else and
reflect badly on the Hall of Fame but
there's also a message about hey don't
talk for half an hour either because we
it's going to be hot out there we don't
be sick oh your Saturday exactly yeah
get a little message on you know you if
you go too long if they don't want to
sit around forever did that happen today
- it did not I will rise that was
surprised if there is no message like
that especially I think that eight
inductees issues they could get a long
night they could especially since barb
spoke for 36 minutes left oh man that's
a you'll see a lot of guys getting out -
getting something to drink yeah they
know at that time so I mean who's who's
going to take over Willie Lanier's role
next year yeah I don't know that's a
question that hasn't been answered yet I
think that's something we have to
consider I don't know that we get to
vote on it I would assume that we would
yeah but that question has to be
answered here pretty soon
I bet urban would want to do that I bet
Michael Irving and I bet you people
won't let him
why is he he's not very brief he's going
to do all the talking okay so you've got
to have a sense of timing
yes timeliness yeah although I write
that disqualify like propriety to the
interest institution and what's about so
his hidden room every but you've been in
the House of Representatives do you
understand if if it's a non-starter on
the floor it can't be brought to yo ya
exact same exact list are you saying his
Urban's I think he's an on Saturday
I wouldn't say that about everybody many
guys that would not would not be I
wouldn't I wouldn't cross off the list
so quickly but I think I can cross him
off pretty safe Steve look I think some
others are waiting for you to head back
to your hotel
so I'll be host of tonight's jacket
dinner I will keep it brief okay I will
notice big very long because I
understand that that it's not about me
it's about the jackets and it's also
about getting out and getting to Jerry
Jones's party or something like that so
it's a funny thing you'll enjoy I'm
looking forward to Steve good to see you
so thank you sir anytime at Steve
Largent one of the all-time great
receivers and certainly Seattle Seahawks
here live in Canton Ohio here on the
Rich Eisen show good to see you see you
guys you got it absolutely Steve Largent
here the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that video be sure to download our app
and I'll be sure to move week six games
to Saturday for that wedding you have to
go to